just one week after buying Twitter Elon
Musk gutted its Workforce firing up to
half of its 7 500 employees at Twitter
headquarters in San Francisco there were
no laid off workers filing out clutching
boxes of their personal effects all the
firings were done by email some
employees tweeted in colorful language
denouncing what they see as a callous
and impersonal method of termination I
think it's going to create a very tense
environment at Twitter and social media
is really all about creativity employees
have filed lawsuits against Twitter's
new ownership saying the mass firing
violates federal and state laws
requiring 60 days advance notice and
Severance payments musk fired all
Twitter senior Executives last week as
soon as he bought the company for 44
billion dollars
musk also says he wants to charge users
a subscription fee to have their
identities verified on the platform
which has outraged many users musk
describes himself as a free speech
absolutist and fears that Twitter will
relax its moderation under his
management allowing hate speech and
misinformation to flourish has led
prominent advertisers including General
Motors Pfizer Audi Volkswagen and others
to suspend advertising on the platform
experts also expect Elite users in
politics entertainment and other fields
will flee Twitter in droves if its
standards on hate speech or
misinformation are relaxed major leaders
and especially people within government
can't be associated with that on on any
social media platform along that nature
and so they they will be forced to leave
the platform by whoever is is managing
them musk tweeted on Friday that Twitter
has suffered a massive drop in Revenue
which he blamed on unnamed activists
pressuring advertisers musk says he
wants to take Twitter into private
ownership so that its shares would no
longer be publicly traded and it would
no longer be subject to Federal
Securities regulation that's a
complicated regulatory process that
could take years to accomplish and with
all of the lawsuits already filed it all
means plenty of work for lawyers even as
thousands of Twitter employees are now
out of a job Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera San
Francisco